well joining me now is the senior
advisor to Benjamin Netanyahu Mark Reger
Mr Reger thank you uh for joining me uh
in the last two hours a letter from a
number of conservative members of
parliament has gone to the foreign
secretary David Cameron in which they're
demanding that the UK no longer abstain
on resolutions calling for ceasefires at
the UN and saying thousands of bodies
lie under the rubble in particular
number of women and children have been
killed is profoundly shocking too many
Palestinians have died and then this key
line but any measure we are witnessing a
catastrophe of precisely the kind the
1949 Geneva conventions were supposed to
prevent uh what is your response to
that I think they're wrong I think
Israel as you said correctly Pierce
Israel is acting to defend itself to
destroy a a a brutal and ruthless and
horrific enemy uh Hamas which is guilty
of the most terrible crimes against
humanity and our challenge here is is is
to to dismantle hamas's military
capabilities when Hamas of course embeds
itself amongst the civilian
population in in in neighborhoods in
hospitals in schools uh in mosques and
so forth even in un facilities and so
we're trying to be as surgical as is
humanly possible in a very combat
situation let me interrupt you there if
you if I may because you say you're
being Surgical and you always say this
that you're being very prec
very careful not to kill civilians but
in the last 2 days alone we've seen
three Israeli hostages who had no sson
who had a self-made SOS Banner that they
were holding uh they were clearly not
terrorists and they were shot dead by
Israeli forces and then we have these
two women killed outside a Catholic
Church you that the pope has called
terrorism based on his information that
he's got from the Archbishop in in in
Jerusalem this is I'm afraid not
indicative of a fighting force that is
trying to be surgical or precise it is
actually lending uh I would say support
to the notion that President Biden put
out that it's
indiscriminate so let's let's talk about
those two issues specifically let's
start with the the the three hostages
who were tragically killed you know the
fighting in Gaza in that particular part
of Gaza has been very tense close
quarter combat face-to-face fighting and
it's it's very difficult and it our
soldiers claim and this is being
investigated of course that obviously
they perceive the three as a threat
incorrectly and tragically you know in
all sorts of urban Warfare you you have
what the experts called Blue on on
Blue they were they waving a they were
waving a white a white piece of cloth
was SOS
you know they were clearly not Hamas
terrorists unless you've been killing a
number of Hamas terrorists you've been
waving white cloths with SOS and
surrender on them which I don't think
you have these these people were killed
and they were turned out to be Israeli
hostages I mean it's an absolute tragedy
um but to Simply dismiss it as sort of
Blue on Blue it seems to me it wasn't an
accident they were deliberately killed
and they were literally holding a cloth
saying SOS I mean it's hard to think of
a more blatant a more blatant killing of
innocent people than this isn't it it's
worse than blue and blue because they
are civilians there weren't even
combatants yes and they were were you
know they were freeing obviously running
away from
Kamas uh one of our problems in this was
was the soldiers on the ground did not
have a briefing that they could expect
to see hostages walking down the street
so to speak uh we expected to see
hostages in tunnels in dark rooms
imprisoned and the idea that they'd be
walking around uh somehow free was was
was a surprise and why sh anybody
holding an SOS
Banner would they shoot a Palestinian
that was doing that a Palestinian C your
assumption your assumption which could
be correct Pierce but it also might be
incorrect is that the soldiers who fired
the shots saw all that and this has to
be investigated obviously when it was
over that all this was discovered but we
have to find and has to be investigated
what did the soldiers see at the time
it's clear that they perceived that this
was a threat and we know that there was
fighting in that area there was uh uh
there was hostile fire from the location
more or less where the where the three
were coming from both before and after
this tragic event so we have to
investigate we have to get to the bottom
but I can tell you this the the chief of
staff of the Israeli military the most
high senior officer in uniform he uh he
spoke publicly earlier and and he said
very clearly of course that the idea of
shooting someone who is way you know
holding a white flag and and and so
forth that is that is against our code
that's the against our Rules of
Engagement he was crystal clear and he
even stressed he even stressed it it's
not connected to them being hostages
even if they had been gazan Palestinians
that would have been wrong Behavior
against our code of conduct and let me
explain why for two reasons one for
moral reasons it's against it's against
the morality of the army but also from a
tactical point of view because if you
can take prisoners uh then you get
information you get intelligence in
other words the idea so it was obviously
it has to be investigated but the the
chief of star said clearly this is
against our code of conduct what
happened to the soldiers who fired the
bullets so there there's an
investigation going on and from have
they been withdrawn from the from the
battlefield well well first of all we
have to see what the investigation comes
out how do you investigated if they
still out there fighting have you have
you brought them back no I'm sure the in
the ways the military does these
investigations is always very thorough
because we want to learn the lessons and
let's be frank the families of the three
people do you do you know if they're
still in active fighting or the soldiers
or whether the soldiers responsible have
been
withdrawn I I don't have the answer that
question I simply don't know I can ask
the military and get you an answer
surely you would agree with me it'd be
pretty extraordinary if they're still
out there having committed this atrocity
it's what it is it's a tragedy it's also
an atrocity three hostages who were
literally fleeing for their lives to
what they thought was the safety of
their own side have been just killed in
Cold Blood having held a sign up saying
SOS I mean at the very least I think the
world would expect that the people
concerned who fired those bullets have
been withdrawn from active service until
this is properly
investigated so once again I ask the
idea but I can say the following that
there was no attempt at all to try to
hush things up we we openly admitted
this the Army came straight out and
spoke to the families and said this was
a terrible accident and it will be
looked into and there'll be a thorough
investigation and the and the and the
evidence and what the investigation
reveals will be shared with the families
of the three hostages who who who were
killed uh we're going to be uh uh the
Army is going to be very transparent on
what's happened here we owe it to
ourselves so these things don't happen
again and we owe it to the families are
you going to be as transparent about
what happened at the Catholic church
that the pope described as an act of
terrorism and given the Archbishop of
Westminster says he simply doesn't
believe the IDF when it claims it didn't
do
it so will investigate that as well we
are in the process of doing so uh uh
we're we're looking at the situation
closely your snip did
it we we at the moment yes I I can say
the following our forces do not
deliberately Target civilians we
definitely don't deliberately Target was
it IDF snipers who fired the bullets so
once again we don't this is still being
investigated but I can say the following
Piers we don't deliberately Target C say
Mr with respect Church we're talking
about two incidents where that's exactly
what's happened and why it's happened is
crucially important to the credibility
of The Wider statements that you've been
making on behalf of the Israeli
government about whether you are being
indiscriminate that's why it's so
important and again I just ask you a
simple question you must know you knew
immediately you'd fired the bullets that
killed the hostages you must equally
have known immediately whether your
snipers have shot these two women
outside the Catholic Church you
literally just have to ask the question
so this was this happened this happened
over the weekend you must have had
enough time now to establish was it
Israeli snipers because earlier today
you were denying it denying the
suggestion it may have been IDF but the
Archbishop says that's a lie so what is
the sit a with the with these
killings so so let me please answer by
saying what needs to be said it's not
like someone is ready is hanging around
with a gun and and indiscriminately
shooting we're talking about combat
zones where where
of question
was did IDF soldiers shoot those two
women you know the answer it's it's
still be looking into and I'm sure that
will be putting out a report I can't
prejudge the idf's report beer you
understand that you've already prejudged
hang on you've already prejudged the
killing of the hostages and said you
know for a fact you did that why do you
not know for a fact you killed these two
women or not because we had the bodies
here of the
three and there was immediately shown to
be CH I'm not sure we've got the bodies
of the two women I don't know where they
are I I don't know what the situation is
we will get to the bottom it just wasf
who who who who were these snipers who
women outside a Catholic Church in Gaza
would because we know there was fire
there
this you see the way it's being
presented incorrectly is that somehow
there was people at a church going to
pray or praying and and suddenly the IDF
came and attacks no that wasn't the
situation Pierce we know there were
firefights in that area we know our
forces took hostile fire so it's quite
possible that it was Israeli forces but
it's also possible it was bullets from
the other side but I think I'm sorry but
you are stretching my credulity to try
and make me think you don't know the
answer after all this time given how
clear you've been about the other
incident an IDF C I'm sure a full IDF
report will come out shortly and I urge
you please be patient it's it's
worthwhile waiting for the full report
and if it transpires as everybody
believes and as the Archbishop of
Westminster said had come directly from
information on the ground that he
believed was credible uh related to him
by the Archbishop of Jerusalem and what
the pope himself has called an act of
terrorism if that turns out to be indeed
the work of the IDF again what would
your response be
so I can give you from the P an example
from the past Pierce where there was a
situation on the beach in ba in Gaza
this was in one of the pre previous
rounds of of conflict and I remember it
well because I was personally inv I
don't want to go into previous incidents
it doesn't because I'm giving you I'm
giving you president the pope has
directly accused you of
terrorism no but I do think I do think
it's incumbent on the on you as a
government to very very very quickly
tell the world what happened here citing
previous incidents in previous Wars and
conflicts is kind of meaningless frankly
I mean no but but I'm but I but judge us
by our track record because in the past
we have come clean when there was an
accident and we we Mis misidentified a
Target and we killed it people and
that's what I'm starting to tell you we
have come and admitted that we've made a
mistake you must know if you had snipers
in that area by that church you shot
people you must know that but if there
was a fir fight and there were shooting
from both
sides we have to look into this were ham
terrorist there were Hamas terrorist
just to be clear your position is there
were Hamas terrorists inside a Catholic
church with a bunch of the location I
didn't say that I said in the location
in location of the church when do you
think and they were firing at our people
and our forces return fire if it turns
out as the pope has has alleged uh and
in fact stated as fact it was act to
terrorism what will Israel do about that
but can can I say the following which I
don't accept in the accusations I can
accept the possibility
that they were killed unintentionally
caught up in the crossfire I do not
accept that they were deliberately
targeted by the IDF we do not Target
civilians we do not Target churches
right and terrorism definition of
terrorism the problem terrorism with
respect the deliberate targeting of the
innocent un unfortunately in the last 48
hours you have shot and killed three
Israeli hostages and it is believed IDF
forces have also shot and killed two
completely innocent women outside a
Catholic church so this constant refrain
that you're not targeting innocent
civilians is not born out by the reality
of IDF forces targeting and killing
innocent
civilians no but no I disagree and if
you'll allow me to finish the sentence
please Piers there's a huge difference
between a policy that deliberately
targets civilians that's what Kamas do
yes and between civilians inadvertently
getting caught up in the crossfire
between combatants between the Israeli
forces you call it Crossfire the
allegation is that all five of these
victims were deliberately shot dead the
two women by snipers and the three by in
the first place no let's be clear if
there is a trial right let's let's say
the accusation against the soldiers who
killed the three hostages it wouldn't be
a murder trial it would be a trial if
there was a trial and I don't know there
will be yes but but they would be
accused of negligence or of not
misidentifying a Target yes murder and
terrorism is the deliberate targeting of
the incident I understand and it's not
clear that in either of these cases that
applies right but it may well be that
that's what what happened you can't rule
that out either well that's why you've
got to do an
investigation right but you know it
shouldn't take very long to ask whether
you had snipers in that area you shot
women outside a church but I I know for
a fact we had combatants in the area but
the the fact is did they in fact fire
the bullets that killed the two women
once again let's wait for the
investigation and as I said in the past
when we've made mistakes we have
admitted it there's a track record there
I you remember I want to to show you a
picture this is of uh uh IDF bombs and
they've inscribed on them the names of
actually a number of people who've been
guests on the show Muhammad hijab Andrew
Tay and also one of my next guests Jen
weager um what is your response to
that maybe IDF soldiers are watching
your show is that possible yeah but do
you think it's uh a a sensible thing to
be doing to be putting names like this
on these
bombs well first of all it's obviously
the this is some soldiers trying to be
funny or creative but it there's a
history here going back to the first
world war isn't there not of soldiers
drawing pictures on on on shells and so
forth it's it's something that soldiers
have done I'm not justifying it but I
think British soldiers have done it
sounds like you are justifying it to me
sorry no I'm just putting it into
historical context okay uh Mark RV I
appreciate you joining me thank you very
much thanks for having me
sir